hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast holo tomography techniques for
3d label-free imaging of live cells and
tissues it is presented by paul park PhD
an associate professor in the department
of physics at christ director of the
time-reversal mirror creative Research
Center and co-founder and CTO of tunnel
Q I am Judy O'Rourke of lab roots and I
will be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots laberd's is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events in
webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box it
appears on the screen
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the ask a question box
to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Park I will now turn the presentation
over to him hello to the hosts and
guests and I like to present a principle
of the Holodomor appear in each
application in life seven teachers so oh
this is for an hour I like you trying to
provide some each combination and if you
have any questions you can contact me by
email I try to answer that so I'd like
to start talking about the motivations
of by religion as you know he mentions
after the inventions of brightly
microscope it was not easy to visualize
life as a teacher because there
since they run on the video waiting
lines so when you trying to put a bunch
concerns or teachers like you materials
onto the color slides and if you use
right a microscope they is very
transparent so in order to solve these
issues he dodged pieces
originally he came up with very clever
idea called phase contrast microscope
the principle of edge contrast
microscope is to convert optical the
directional information which is called
a phase information in physics into in
health information by simply inserting
the plastic filter into position
microscope we can convert these low
contrast images or bollocky centers to
high contrast information and imaging so
that you can now see on 10 pounder ease
as well there's also the organelles be
using any labeling
Oxygen's labels or dyes the Troy people
still use pH contrast microscope in
biological lab and medical hospital and
it has a few limitation the one of the
limitation is that it does only provide
to the information that's three
dimensional information and second
limitation is that it already provides
qualitative representations of the steam
cellular imaging she means you have
information about where the cell
boundaries and where the nucleus and so
on but you don't have any quantitative
information about federer
young different tasks which involve the
volume and concentration and you don't
have any information in quantity or the
tariff numbers and people also use the
fruits in microscope by injecting some
dyes or is placing the fruits and
proteins and related to the target
molecules of air each s now you have the
great contrast to highlight and locate
where is the specific proteins of your
interest in lifestyle but I'll even do
this video
deep roots microscope
has opened the doors to molecular
biology and molecular diagnosis but one
of the key limit engine is that you have
to modify the cell so which means the
style is not anymore its intrinsic state
and even more it has also prepared a
cell like overnight education and
transportation
I'm just not ideal for the case that you
wanna wash the cell on mediate so about
the beauty case the technique called the
positive edge engines were developed a
method has been developed and which
enables the imaging so like a cell
without using any excellence later so
this is a topic that I like to talk
about on throughout this webcast and
this is basic principle every material
has the ill effect win this war has
refractive index and though ever has
reflective in their cells and tissues
and bacteria has their own infective in
this distribution the meaning of effect
mean that it governed the speed of light
and the light has ensued as testing
materials for example um as you can see
in this slide when you shine a laser
beam or any light sue this particle
samples such as human let yourself um
since let yourself star platinum has
effective index greater than that
- the medium what happens like passing
through this cell is slower than the
medium the resulting into the
alterations of the direction of the
light at the transmission which is
called light refraction and as like
transmitted through this temple it has
the undeformed general information or
the in other words the altered it what
it affected by this light has
information about an uncritical shape or
a cell but unfortunately using the
commissioner microscope or negative you
don't have access
to this duration information or face
information the lies however if you
employ the principle of along lately
what interpretive elementary by
introducing the second laser beam
interview with young the samples that
affected me but now you can convert
attribution information into intense
information which is called Apollo
repentance whether it's a pebble
attaches by analyzing those patterns
captured by the carrier or gave a lot of
opinions then you can be tree through
all this information to diet missionary
information about cells what motor
respond on the admission but this is a
2d hundred tel aviv any meetings or
individuals delayed processor and now
you can see they on the Tony Hsieh which
is characteristic of the human life
Purcell and then a lot more we have the
quantitative information about the
sickness of the sale in micrometer unit
so we have done some studies using these
two dimensional quality defects innings
by measuring on the wiper of seven
letters and optic glass slice and we
also able to measure a tiny vibration in
the segment going on the lettuce cell
which has the odors odors so 250
nanometers and we from those
quantitative measurements about
evaluation about geometry
- Amanda Purcell we can also retrieve a
mechanical property of this human a
cluster so those information provides
elatedly
the quantitative mention of the cell but
this is not a 3d imaging
even though we have some Pedialyte
ancient techniques you don't so that
looks like a three-dimensional but it in
terms of information it only has
two-time user information in XY space it
has only the height of the young
individual sample so this is a two
dimension information and which is also
called supportive information such that
the atomic force microscopy can in
generally in order to to access to the
three dimension information or to model
to model information we have to do one
step alter which has done in do it x-ray
CT domain and if you imagine ethnicity
or the computer if this is feminine
young maximum area hospitals if you open
the machine for ethnicity while its
operating you will see the rotations of
source of x-ray beam and detector and
while is operating it rotates over the
human bodies and it emerges multiple two
dimensional x-ray images
wrongish by organized computational the
analogous steps you can reconstruct
three-dimensional information of a human
body without any basic process this is
how many doctors do some diagnosis
respect on this x-ray CT data so our
technique over the Apollo tomography
ensure the HTT is the optical illusion
electricity so similarly them are the
ethnicity li construct a
three-dimensional human body ATT
measures three dimensional distributions
of the individual cell by measuring
multiple through the holograms as a
functions operators in the mission angle
so the principles and physical things
were saying in ethnicity it is a 3 min
but in a CT it used layering in x-ray CT
images x-ray of the TiVo dilutional body
in a CT in measures and reconstruct
three-dimensional holograms of the
refractive index
one of the lightest esthetician so using
this technique our group a minute ago in
the world have addressed a bunch of
problems and medical problems but
basically we have developed a series of
the microscope in order to mentor this
3-dimensional effect mean this
distribution I'm not going into details
of the optical part but to make love to
me belongs we should we use the laser
beam and if being instancing su this
sample after passing through before
passing through sample we have covered
many meters which is which was used to
scan the laser means it's getting the
angle laser beam impinging on the sample
so after passing through the sample the
defective light is projected onto the
camera plane and without our with just
this configuration this is same as a
conventional private microscope so that
you don't have any young the quantity
information in order to do 3d on the
following images what the interferometry
imaging you have to split incoming laser
me into two paths using beam splitter by
a device called the ps1 in the diagram
and then the stripping which is called
to your left front spin will interfere
at the camera being it's a stem
Christopher tipping so by measuring the
patterns at the CCD what the camera
crane which is called the hollowness and
now we have a two-dimensional the lower
it images as I said in order to do 3d
you have to scan the laser beam you can
angle the laser beam inching impinging
on just simple so by scanning the
angular carbon emission gears we can
measure multiple to the Holograms as a
function of a to measure angles so now
we are at this T on D it fundamentally
presentation but those are the XY and
so produce measure the Holograms by
applying some algorithms we way we can
the tree is an creature information
about a sample as far as space
information over solution information
about a simple and then by applying a
leak insertion algorithm similarly done
in the x-ray CT we can retrieve one
three dimensional distribution of
refractive index of the sample from
those multiple treaty a lot of
measurements and in the bottom of slide
you will see that on distension of city
200 grams of the individuals let Russell
using this technique but on the Left
Rossiter look like the norm because
these cells are the monitor in Catalan
press down so intersperse a left-hand
side you will see on the land rose and
infected by malaria inducing parasites
in each oasis so in the lab on the
bottom you'll see small touch which has
refractive index lower than the side of
provider on the Left row so that is the
pollution where the parasite has invaded
and in the middle we have the truth of
joy stage which is absolutely an impact
in pensions by the parasites about the
young twenty powers you will see the
formations of the Hashim ozone which is
increased authorization forms of him at
the digestions of the human proteins by
the parasite and which has been highly
effective in text but that can be seen
the meal of the cell and in the right
panel you will see the very late stage
of male efficient call these headers
days you can also see the pictures
containing the lake produced at a site
so even though we haven't used any
labeling was paying any word any
preparation we were able to imaging and
retrieved quantitative information about
the cell especially for this case
electrodes they are infected by malaria
parasites
so using this HTT
technique or many reasons
my one has the UM addressed the various
types of tea on the study in cellular
biology and medicine so including the
studies on the lateral cell and its
biophysical what a possibility limited
to you during that person has been
studied and nowadays many people trying
to adapt this technique enough to if
floor explorer some feel the chest is
Tom Selleck storage and immuno therapy
and you know colleges and microbiology
and so on
so I like to introduce a few
representatives study so what we see
here is the images of the leave yourself
happen to site captured by HD technique
since this is three-dimensional
techniques you will see XY slides and
whitey and rxg we have the Tamil crappy
information and those are the
cross-cultural wrong those three axes
and now what you see here is the
refractive index distribution and also
the color correspond to a specific
values of lipid effective index things
that the cell even though we haven't
used any labeling agents you will see
that you can see the meandering of the
spell as well as T on the u.s. membrane
nucleoli and from the pentacle
structures having highly effective index
tools are the lipid trauma because
liquid as very highly effective intense
compared to the cytoplasm which was
caused to come from by using
conventional
eleven technique podium the lipid
membrane using nine left eyes so as I
said since this information provides the
quantitative values and properties of
the cell we were able to retrieve and
calculate the value of concentration and
other parameters in quantitative manners
so religion is the meaning of refractive
index in biologists it has done the
information about the protein
concentration because there is a in the
linear relationship between the electric
team default different index values of
the ATM cell versus the concentration of
proteins there's a linear relationship
so once we jump off at the one point of
the sale we can measure the refractive
index values of Steinberg legend when
you have the values one point eight
something then those values can be
directly and literally translated into
the printing protocol situation in plant
potentially test so in fact this
effective in this distribution is the
person concentration map so now we have
parliamentary information and protein
concentration information and if you
multiply those two numbers then if you
give a like give you each trying mass of
the cell so that the mass of the
individual organs what the cells can be
quantified without we put in the cells
onto a little bit so at this point let
me explain the pros and cons of this
technique audacity the first limitation
this is label-free techniques since we
personally cause any preparation or
fixation or the introductions of the
dyes for the young person proteins you
can see the three-dimensional shape
imaging surface demo in each negative
stage but this is false advantages the
advantages is that effect that it
provides positive information compared
to the through the microscope which
provides the qualitative information
about the rotations of specific target
proteins or the molecules this
information that we measure is
alliterative index which is physical
parameters
highly reproducible and the intrinsic
obstacle parameters so with any
furthermore those values of defecting
this can also be translated into the
critical situation in quantity - so it
has the capability or the quantitative
imaging nonetheless it has one
limitation
another limitation is that it does not
provide the good molecular specificity
what I mean by that even though if you
use a cheesy technique you can precisely
measure three dimensional distribution
so the up cell in terms of the effective
index but you don't have any information
about the molecular specific the
information about TM on the self example
when you have measured he is specific
values at specific location or stem and
you don't have any idea what kind of
molecules or proteins are contributing
that specific values that's why you're
not claiming his technique will replace
the existing person based the
microscopic techniques but I believe it
will go on complimentary with
conventional optical microscopy
technique or the stereo if I reach a
medicine and in the following slide I
like to introduce some of the
underrepresented walls from my grooves
and other relatives
I'm using this activity in various
application a process of application is
the metrologist so in level 3 minutes
and people use the machine called a CVC
complete blood count machine if you put
your tube containing a virgin and cream
into the Machine and using the light
scattering techniques or the electric
impedance sensor the tree the various
parameters about electro tell my process
we involved the white blood cell count
natural cells tip volume and as you know
the letter
with pleasure and human concentration
and he movements those numbers could
quantify by using the biggest city so
technically in civics a machine however
one of the limitation of CDC is that it
only provides the average Bentley for
like thousands of the 100 let Brazil and
even furthermore they even destroyed the
Saracino to achieve such parameters on
all of the motivation is a driving force
in medicine is that people trying to
understand on some disease by analyzing
individual stairs in tissues of SRAM
bodies on similarly that people have
understood on previously people have
understood the young how these cells are
watching by analyzing dividual molecules
composed of a cell now we're trying to
many people trying to understand that if
this by analyzing the bit of style but
the single set profiling so for the so
view of this little cell and even white
blood cell if you introduce ATT you can
retrieve various phenomena such as
pollen of the red blood cell and surface
area which is very difficult to the tree
using conventional methods and prone to
be effective in disparities you can
retrieve and calculate a human
concentration and by multiplying human
concentration in value you also get
really intense and body measuring the
fast 2d honorary measurements you can
also authorized to use to retrieve and
measure the penetration in a cell
membrane from which you can also access
to the mechanical properties of the
dylan hotel and those parameters can be
obtained simultaneously at the
individual level so clearly to walk or
with other mental hospitals and we have
measured
such as volume immigrant concentration
and him only content and so on or focus
on guru is healthy and second guru gives
I don't efficiency anemia so to be the
electrical psychosis and fun and release
the enter to the tree if your site to
assist those are the genetic disorder so
since we can measure multiple parameters
at the individual level we were able
three tree we can also perform the
correlative on delicious between those
parameters that was not possible using
conventional message and we are now
trying to understand those young cattle
class or in other words with the
unrelated information to predict the
disease autism diagnosis application and
using its mythology can also study
infectious disease the dissident Brazil
infected by the embodied shape and size
it has shares of the possibilities with
malaria parasite and the problem of
studying of this publisher panel side is
that those parasites are very difficult
to relate using commercial message that
it was a hundred and limitation in the
past own but if you introduce this ACD
technique we were able to measure three
dimensional the effectiveness resolution
of this yourself also they are affected
by Merida pedestal the Babesia parasite
we can look at where is the positions of
the parasites and we can observe
achieved various quantitative indicator
parameters out of those information and
do 50 on a lot of the application in
example that is technique can also be
used for the impact infectious disease
but the problem is this its system the
built in my lab in Kies and as you can
see here the system looks very
complicated so previously we have
collaborators who
simple tools and we have imagined those
images using a setup
and that was not very very affected by
arm because it will be a good idea that
instead of like measuring the spell
after the of transporting the sample
from the hospital survival app I think I
it will be much more be helpful for the
apologies or the medical doctors have
this machine by their desk next to
patient and that's just a sample and
it's time we utilize this machine in
order to find the new medical diagnosis
or the energy find some new in your
findings and the problem was it since
the system is so complicated it is not
easy to be build by the non expert for
the mortise since the system is still
very delicate it requires but if density
calibration and maintenance so one of
the most important part was the governor
mentoring mirrors which is in the middle
of this type ischium the photograph that
was used to scan the laser beam on the
angle is impinging on the sample even
though we can scan the laser beam with
very high speed below things it is very
prone to the mechanical vibration and
nearly 3 noise ill acquire some manual
the alignment shared behind before you a
measurement so I thought it is not good
idea
you have to season in bachelor and
hospitals that was three years ago we
came up with one idea to put everything
here into a small machine so the season
is now commercialized by the company Tom
with you
and the size of Steel machine is about
their small desktop computer everything
is fully automated
which means if you put your cell phone
into the same procedure was microscope
and click the button and it measures
three dimensional distribution of
Castelo our last answer
one second so the key technique was to
implement the introductions of TMD
digital micrometer device which has yom
kippur not choke the individual meters
can be flipped on and off and it has
about like compute the tens of thousands
in the individual meters into this
watching compactor so one of the
provisions of the DMD Convention on the
usage of DMD is the theater projector so
in fact what do you see here on the
screen and you have a deal with
projection is that if you flip back to
the images of these leaders and after
magnification so when you have a bright
pixel on your screen using the Dirac
projector which means its own stage
this corresponding spot picture the DMV
arena and if you have a task pixel that
means DM the aux page after tilting so
that the beam is not passing through
this land of the theater projector the
very color if can it just in the only on
the dues can't pass the human eyes so
that you do not recognize the on its own
little value you will see based on
ditches features and it'll be a
continuous color the conventional
applications to DT the projectors
interpretation but we thought money can
be used or its HD Tapani by projecting
some patterns like the grating patterns
of the DMD so that if you illuminate a
laser beam on the DMD panels and
actually flexion if you have the filter
patterns you have the effective lines
and the different light and the angle
and the direction of the difficult life
can be fully controlled by the patterns
you have projected onto the MD so
without having any mechanical the only
movement which can prove cause of some
vibration and noise he Stanley
we spent high speed and high stability
so that you can reconstruct
three-dimensional tomograms this paid
high precision so this is fitting
disallow message and using this
commercialize for purchase of the HDD
technique many groups including the
young to see such it they are studying
the very interesting on the search and
trying to they also explore the new on
topical studies and let me show you some
example so these is photograph shown
here is a the electro cells and white
blood cell and other side measured by
this HTTP techniques so the net
processor now you can see it's clear
tuna shade and the white blood cell
motor side you can see the cell membrane
as well as beyond the nucleus and
hepatocyte we can see cell membrane in
plasma grain deeply and each other
having highly effective index so the
load dinner then HD technique generate
if the encourage came on in terms of the
different unique values of the cell and
similarly i'm done in every city you can
also provide the pseudo coloring
based on the values of the defective
index so that you can highlight the
structures of interest to offer better
visualization in control when you can
change the transparency visualization
you can change afterwards than the resin
the yellow data in terms of refractive
index column has been captured and
stored in the computer and on since this
technique has a special resolution in X
going domain about hundred ten nanometer
in y-axis is about 360 nanometer
you can see of subcellular structures
with very high resolution so tableaus
you can see the obsolete diameter shape
of the individual cancer cell line and
in the bottom this is the human platelet
Pipo activation and after
to patient the cyber planner is about an
one micrometer when you can even see the
inside of the plague lab and AB
situation you can clearly see the food
approach which is indicator of this
activation of the individual the
internet and if you love the study is
the microbiologist or the bacteria's you
see using conventional bathroom
microscope it only generates the outline
of the individual bacteria from those
images infinite exchange recipes is what
you only have the quantitative
information but since we can measure
3-dimensional delivering this
distribution layer yourself now we can
study beyond the more and achieve more
in interest information about on the
cells in its native the physiological
state the motor measurement situation is
requires so the maintenance control of
co2 co2 level the temperature in unity
was very crucial we can also provide
those the accessories small into better
fit into this temple stage and then all
of the reason most elegant on is the
combination between
three-dimensional process a
three-dimensional effective index
measurements and this new also note the
commercialization of commercializes the
HD technique in measure is three
thousand effective to movements of the
cell a same time he can measure three
channels three different images of the
specific spell so there are usually
three of two different information the
more information and quantitative
information using the trickiness
confidence and same time you can utilize
this molecular information by
introducing the on roots of protein so
that we believe this technical kottar
nuu the attractions or the understudy so
that the people can also to use their
protocols based on process and easily
each young employee and into
this new technique for the research and
I'm prepared on several movies which can
show your capillary and the potentials
of the HD technique and in the following
slides we will mount immediately and
showing how we can measure on various
types of certain tissues for using HD
technique hi so the person which shows
how individual packages can go and
divide and finally for me
the defendants amazing PI over 2 more
weapon
and in the second movie you will see the
time lapse dynamics of light cell which
is the HEPA hepatocytes but since
there's a life and happy you can see the
movement of sister organize that finally
can city on the net which is the cell
and remaining mr. Davis one rotation
left imaginative or sweetie and this
movie is the own the time-lapse movies
or the he lessons and other point a
publicist in Casey the hallmark of
metastasis which is Maghrib living so
and after some time the cell is finally
stopped working and stated the three
dies and in the final movie we show the
elegance with label three images and
this movie shows timeless images of the
countess's taking these this target
cancer cell and this movie was stated
for every dollar statement and up to six
hours to successor and we haven't used
any living agent we can see the movie so
this time said for a long time and in
this movie you can see that the katisa
as
nice target cancer cell and followed by
the sale induce the apoptosis of
targeted and finally said tire can said
it's with the story in this movie she
okay so we have come I have shown the
several the ellipticity of the movies
the time-lapse treaties and also the
50th images of individual cells and
tissues in Asia technique and to
summarize the private rival microscope
was designed and invented for emitting
small after but it was not ideal for
imaging we polish our cells and tissues
because they are transparent under you
know of Caligula's page contrast
microscope it provides high contrast for
transparent cells and I sell images and
tissues without using any labels but
this is not sweetie and it doesn't
provide commentary of information and a
shitty technical provides
three-dimensional and contouring on
total information about certain teachers
without introducing exogenous flavors
and dyes so throughout this video clip I
have gone through the basic principles
about the engines and techniques and
application and some of these people
study saying the absolute apologies and
powerful information you may want to
refer to a glute written by Jerry
purposefully novice campaign page
musings of stairs and tissues we can
also leave virtual review articles
published in centers and under the legal
articles in its application in
biomedicine will be come out in native
photonics in October so 2018 you can
also refer to data and we have
conference the oldest copy or the font
of the greatest images and this is still
the Queen
for the optical scientists and balances
and even the medical doctors at Twitter
to discuss and also walk together on how
utilize and we developed this example in
order to move forward to better things
understandings of the cells and the
disease is that I like to you thankful
you're listening thank you all right
thank you dr. Park for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and we'll address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left of
your presentation window if your
question into the box it appears on the
screen and click the send button where
speaker will follow up with your
questions via email let's get started
first question is what are the pros and
cons of using HT compared to existing
microscopy techniques it doesn't require
any accident labels because it utilized
intrinsic multiple parameter for imaging
you can do by Vasily imaging without
using any excellence labels that
whispers advantages and second
advantages is that the meaning of
reflective index has young information
about the protocol situation so by
measuring the refractive index for MEMS
or cell using HT technique you can reach
we are totally invention such as the
protein concentration protein content of
its also organelles as well as data and
one of the limitation of gaze Asia
tweeted me it does not provide food
is officially even though you can
precisely measure 3d it should be chef
so big that you mean this but you do not
have access to the information about
what I'm gonna give us our proteins I
continuing at specific values of
effectiveness thank you
next how small an object can HT image of
a city the if you use objects having
which means how much angle there is
nothing for imaging process or and if
you use young typical high-end objective
lens which covers all to light stability
views of the patient angles the duration
go down to a hundred nanometer in XY
domain and exist we have the electrician
of 300 nanometer and those failures can
be variable depending on the choice of
the wavelength and the choice of the
object length you cannot pull down to
the on size of iris about tens of
nanometer because in order to do in
order to access this information
alternative it is that the good way
without introducing some technical
errors and the stipulated microscope
well thank you I would like to once
again thank dr. Park for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through December 27th 2018 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement when your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now thank you for joining us we hope
to see you again soon goodbye